and suddenly I'm not thinking about my
career and when I stop thinking about my
career and thinking about how I can
advance myself it exploded dude it
exploded I swear to God I was like I
started doing these little insta Church
videos that were more for me because
they ground me I I we all know that when
you teach a subject is when you truly
know um if you understand it and it
helps you cement your understanding of
it and so for me it's a practice of like
do I know this subject doesn't make
sense to me can I explain it to somebody
um and also sharing ideas that I think
are fun to talk about that nobody does
because they're not commercial but um I
started doing that and I I I told my
wife before I posted the first video I
said I want to make sure you're okay
with me never working again in the
business like if I have to be a plumber
or something to make ends me because I
have a feeling if I start posting these
videos people are going to think I'm
some kind of nut job and I'm never going
to work again and she's like I'm with
you you know and like this is you being
honest and authentic and I you know I
like what you have to say and go for it
you know so I had her support and I was
like all right I'm never gonna work
again and and it was it was entering
this space through that honest authentic
place of like of of assuming an identity
that was wrapped in
career that that then the career takes
off it's the most B bizarre thing that
life does for us when we let go of what
doesn't matter you know and that that's
been my experience you
know on a on a similar level I I do feel
like you know cuz my whole life I was
you know not my whole life but since
high school theater and college and
plays and Off Broadway and movies and TV
and I got to a certain point where I'm
just like something's
missing I've been CH I've been chasing
this
and I've had great success and I'm very
grateful but I'm still empty and why is
that it doesn't make sense like people
look at you and you're right they you
know you have a little money you have
nice things you have good friend you
have a career what why what is it and
that's doing the work and that's working
on yourself and which I have
done but also obviously learning to love
yourself which we talk about a lot which
is very difficult because you know if
you grow up not feeling loved and not
feeling like you uh are worthy or good
enough then how how the hell so you have
to stop and go hey I'm not I can't blame
this anymore what is the issue how do we
fix this and when I started doing things
and this wasn't that long ago I I was I
took a little break from acting for a
while and I did like little you know
like you know some things but I
thought try doing things that you you
really
like that you really love doing
passions and all of a sudden in the last
year
two these passions have turned into
things inadvertently oh that's great you
know it's like I always wanted to write
a kids book I and I and I sold it and
it's gonna be out I'm like you know I
really want to do this man you know I
want to do this one and by the way it's
the first time in my
life that the
process is just as fun as the outcome if
not more I'm I'm the process because I
used to be like okay 14 hour day to-day
oh what time is it it's okay I only have
six hours left I only have the I am just
enjoying the moment moments and
whether something amazing happens
financially or whatever I'm doing them
because I enjoy them you know I came I
the cake yeah it's it's amazing amazing
that's when you know you're being true
to yourself when you're being true to
yourself the process is the enjoyable
part because the life is the process
then life is working right it feels
right because you're being true to
yourself hey guys I'm doing another live
podcast downtown LA at the Regent
Theater and my special guest for January
24th is Kristen Ritter Breaking Bad
Jessica Jones this is going to be a sold
out event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael rosenbom with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so
excited